hi schön dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet
habt wir sind wieder für euch bei ZDF
heute live und ich freue mich sehr heute
wieder mit euch zu diskutieren wir
sprechen heute über etwas das so oder so
ähnlich schon vor Jahrzehnten in
Deutschland diskutiert wurde nämlich
über die Regeln wie und wer eigentlich
in Deutschland Staatsbürger oder
Staatsbürgerin werden darf
ich bin froh dass wir uns heute 16 Jahre
nachdem sie es nicht geschafft haben
mehrfach angekündigt hatten endlich die
Realität stellen in dem sich dieses Land
am 1.1.20 neues modernes
republikanisches europäische
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht zulegt es geht
im Wesentlichen darum dass die in
Deutschland lebenden Ausländer auch
bereit sind sich einer deutschen
Leitkultur anzuschließen
ja und die Einbürgerung nach Deutschland
aber auch die fachkräftezuwanderung
deren Eckpunkte heute im Kabinett
beschlossen worden die werden gerade
politisch in Deutschland wieder richtig
stark diskutiert und das wollen wir
heute auch und zwar zum einen mit Hakan
Demir er ist Bundestagsabgeordneter der
SPD und Mitglied des Innenausschusses
und Stefan tome Bundestagsabgeordneter
der FDP und parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der FDP-Fraktion
herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute live
hallo schönen Abend Herr Demir wir haben
es eben gesehen dieses Thema diskutieren
wir in Deutschland schon eine ganze
Weile was glauben Sie denn woran liegt
das dass wir das immer noch diskutieren
ja weil die Reform vor 20 Jahren zwar
ein guter Schritt nach vorne war aber
seitdem haben wir natürlich auch alle
mitbekommen dass es viele Probleme auch
gibt beispielsweise bei der doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft einige Gruppen
beispielsweise aus der Türkei sind davon
ausgeschlossen und wir haben jetzt
gemeinsam in der fortschrittskoalition
die Idee dass wir das jetzt ja
progressiver voranbringen das heißt dass
wir doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft für alle
möglich machen und deshalb gibt's diese
Diskussion gerade und wir werden die
voraufenthaltszeit von acht auf fünf
Jahre runterbringen das heißt dass wir
dann auf dem Niveau von Kanada und USA
sein werden und deshalb haben wir gerade
die Diskussion und ich weiß tatsächlich
selber nicht warum die CDU CSU
tatsächlich die gleichen Sachen die sie
vor 20 Jahren gesagt hat jetzt heute
auch noch mal macht
ja sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen das Thema doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft das wird ja
allerdings auch von der FDP gerade
wieder besprochen Herr Thome werden wir
mit ihrer Partei jetzt so eine neue
leitkulturdebatte führen müssen
das Wort Leitkultur will ich mir nicht
zu eigen machen das Wort ist ziemlich
vergiftet und in falschen Hals genommen
worden was wir wollen ist dass wir ein
modernes Staatsangehörigkeit schaffen
für Menschen die hier bei uns bleiben
wollen die Teil dieser Gesellschaft
werden wollen die zum Gelingen dieses
Landes beitragen den wollen wir ein
Angebot machen auch den roten Teppich
ausrollen wir hier sich bei uns gut
integriert der soll teil und das Landes
werden können darauf kommt es uns an
natürlich kommt auch darauf an dass man
sich kulturell integriert sprachlich
rechtlich und auch wirtschaftlich aber
jetzt ganz viele Menschen und die wollen
wir bei uns willkommen heißen
ich freue mich mit Ihnen darüber gleich
zu diskutieren und es ist noch mal
wichtig zu sagen wir wollen hier heute
über zwei Dinge sprechen nämlich zum
einen über die Reform des
einbürgerungsgesetzes dass in den
letzten Tagen ganz viel diskutiert wurde
und später dann noch über die Eckpunkte
zum
fachkräftezuwanderungsgesetz das wie
gesagt heute im Kabinett beschlossen
wurde wenn ihr die da gerade draußen
zuschaut Fragen an die beiden Experten
habt oder eure Meinung teilen wollt dann
könnt ihr das wie immer ihr könnt mit
uns diskutieren und Fragen stellen
schreibt uns die gerne einfach in die
Chats oder per Mail an ZDF heute - live
at zdf.de jetzt geht's erstmal um die
Reform des einbürgerungsgesetzes in
Zukunft soll es nämlich in Deutschland
für Menschen einfacher werden deutsche
Staatsbürger und deutsche
StaatsbürgerInnen zu werden das ist eine
Idee auf die haben sich SPD grün und FDP
so ziemlich genau vor einem Jahr
geeinigt während der
koalitionsverhandlung und da steht
tatsächlich auch so im Koalitionsvertrag
und was da jetzt genau geplant ist das
erklärt uns jetzt einmal Maike Verlag
violand
es ist ein besonderer Tag der an dem die
Einbürgerungsurkunde ausgehändigt wird
Voraussetzungen sind unter anderem
ausreichende Sprach- und
verfassungskenntnisse die
Bundesregierung will jetzt noch
schneller und leichter einbürgern
bislang beträgt die Wartezeit mindestens
acht Jahre künftig sollen es maximal
fünf sein
auch in Deutschland geborene Kinder
ausländischer Eltern sollen einfacher
deutsche werden können bislang musste
ein Elternteil 8 Jahre in Deutschland
leben geplant sind jetzt fünf Jahre
bei älteren migranten sollen der
Sprachnachweis und der Einbürgerungstest
wegfallen
stattdessen soll künftig die Fähigkeit
zur mündlichen Verständigung ausreichen
auch der Besitz mehrerer
Staatsbürgerschaften würde mit der
Reform einfacher werden bislang muss die
bisherige Staatsbürgerschaft in vielen
Fällen aufgegeben werden dies soll
entfallen
ja so viel Eimer zu Reformen und was
jetzt geplant ist hätte mir warum soll
es jetzt diese Verkürzung der Frist
geben und was erhofft man sich von der
Verkürzung dieser Frist
ja im Grunde geht es darum dass wir als
Gesellschaft verhandeln
wer schnell dazugehören kann und wer
nicht und es macht natürlich immer Sinn
zu sagen dass wir es ermöglichen wollen
dass eine Gruppe von Menschen schnell
dazu gehört und nicht erst nach acht
Jahren und dieses schnell dazu gehören
bedeutet ja auch in einer Demokratie
mitzubestimmen also auch zu wählen oder
auch gewählt zu werden also wir stärken
mit diesem neuen Gesetz auch die
Demokratie es gibt 5 Millionen Menschen
in Deutschland die im Grunde sich einen
Bürgern lassen könnten aber es jetzt
gerade noch nicht machen und wir
erhoffen uns natürlich auch durch diese
Vereinfachung dass mehr Menschen sich
einen Bürgern lassen
und zwar auch mit der nächsten Säule mit
der doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft weil
das hat ja dazu geführt dass
beispielsweise viele Menschen aus aus
der Türkei gesagt haben ich möchte gar
nicht meinen türkischen Pass abgeben und
deshalb kann ich jetzt nicht den
deutschen Pass bekommen oder will ich
gar nicht den beantragen und das wird ja
jetzt natürlich dadurch auch aufgehoben
und dadurch erhoffen wir uns natürlich
auch dass mehr Menschen dann den
deutschen Pass beantragen werden
sie haben gerade schon diese Möglichkeit
der doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft
angesprochen und da hat man ja in den
letzten Tagen auch aus der Union immer
wieder gehört die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft die würde verhindern
dass man sich wirklich vollen Herzens
quasi für eine deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft entscheidet wie
entgegnen sie dem
ja seit über 15 Jahren haben wir die
Hinnahme der doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft also über fünf in
über 50 Prozent der Fällen ist das so
also bei allen EU-Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern ist das so und auch in
verschiedenen anderen Ländern und
letztes Jahr wenn ich mir die Zahlen
angucke also 20021 haben wir die
Hinnahme der doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft in 69% der Fällen und
ich habe keine Debatte in den letzten ja
Jahren dazu gehört wie das aussieht ob
es gut ist oder nicht ich glaube in
einem modernen Staat ist es total normal
dass man sich zugehörig fühlt zu dem
Land und zu dem anderen ich glaube das
ist durchaus möglich und die Realität
zeigt ja auch dass es möglich ist daher
sehe ich da überhaupt keine Probleme
auch jetzt noch mal den ja quasi den
restlichen 30% diese Möglichkeit zu
bieten
sie sind ja auch Teil dieser
Ampelkoalition jetzt hat aber am
Montagmorgen der FDP Generalsekretär
Bijan dieser Rei gesagt seine Partei
können eigentlich die Pläne von Nancy
Feser von der bundesinnenministerin so
nicht mittragen Zitat eine Entwertung
der deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft werde
es mit ihm nicht geben was sagen sie
dazu
also die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft ist
nicht einfach so ein Geschenk dass man
jeden ohne Voraussetzung macht da muss
auch der Nachweis erbracht werden dass
jemand sich gut integriert hat dass er
Teil dieser Gesellschaft werden will
dass in dieser Zeit ablaufen natürlich
erforderlich und das muss angeschaut
werden wie verhält sich jemand zu
unserem Land besteht jemand dazu kann
gut verstehen dass jemand auch sagt ich
will nicht alle Brücken zu einem
Heimatland abbrechen das kann auch mal
erbrechtliche Gründe haben oder
familienrechtliche Gründe aber es muss
jemand eine Beziehung aufbauen zu
unserem Land muss erkenntlich werden
dass er auf Dauer Teil diese
Gesellschaft werden will und das muss
auch gründlich beraten werden das ein
Anreiz dafür besteht dass jemand auch
Anstrengungen Unternehmens um sich bei
uns gut zu integrieren wirtschaftlich
rechtlich sprachlich und kulturell und
deswegen ist es eine gründliche Debatte
die wir vorher führen müssen solche
übers Knie gebrochen werden am Ende des
Tages wollen auch wir das ein modernes
Einwanderungsrecht
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
für unser Land ein Anreiz darstellt sich
hier bei uns gut zu integrieren
diese Töne des
ftp-generalsekretärs die klingen ja aber
schon so ein bisschen ähnlich wie die
Kommentare der Union die es da in den
letzten Tagen gab ne wir haben da gehört
von einer faramschung der deutschen
Staatsbürgerschaft ist da die FDP also
eher an der Union Seite
also von einer verraten kann glaube ich
keine Rede sein auch wir wollen ja eine
fünfjährige voraufenthaltszeit jemand
muss fünf Jahre bei uns im Land leben
niemand verrampft hier irgendetwas und
neben der dem zeitlichen Faktor wollen
wir auch noch gewisse inhaltliche
Führung setzen guter Integration ein
Bekenntnis zu unserem Land und das muss
schon auch weiterhin Voraussetzungen
sein dabei bleiben wir bleiben auch als
FDP
hätte mir weil wir haben jetzt gehört
von irgendwie Integrationsleistung von
einer guten Integration nach Deutschland
was sind denn für Sie zum Beispiel so
Punkte wie integriert sich denn jemand
gut in Deutschland
ja also ich kann ja aus Berlin Neukölln
und wenn man da den Menschen sagt die
seit 10 20 Jahren hier leben ihr seid
jetzt gut integriert oder ihr müsst euch
integrieren dann sagen sie haben im
Moment mal ich bin doch hier geboren
also deshalb
fremdlich bisschen mit dem Begriff
Integration aber rechtlich gesehen ist
da klar was wir meinen im Rahmen des
Staatsbürgerschaftsrechts das ist klar
dass die Person die
Lebensunterhalt gesichert haben muss die
Sprache auf B1 Niveau sprechen muss und
halt die vor Aufenthaltszeit das ist
jetzt im rechtlichen Sinne was wir jetzt
in dem Kontext verstehen als jemand ähm
also das was wir als Voraussetzung da
haben für eine Person die dann in der
Gesellschaft teilhaben sollte das sind
so die Voraussetzungen
und es steht auch in dem Gesetzentwurf
drin dass wir auch bei bestimmten
Personen nach drei Jahren die
Staatsbürgerschaft ja
so auch ermöglichen werden wenn diese
Person beispielsweise auf C1 Niveau
spricht und ehrenamtlich sich engagiert
hat also das ist das was man jetzt im
rechtlichen Sinne als Integration
bezeichnet aber jetzt wenn man kulturell
jetzt unterwegs ist ist das eine
Begrifflichkeit mit denen mit dem viele
Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte jetzt
nicht so viel anfangen können also vom
Begriff her weil sie sagen wir sind ja
schon hier wir sind ja schon hier
geboren wir arbeiten studieren hier ähm
genau und da fremden einige mit dem
Begriff aber nicht weil sie all die
anderen Voraussetzungen nicht hätten wie
gesagt 5 Millionen Menschen haben diese
Voraussetzungen die wir auch im
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht so jetzt auch
ausgelegt haben
also wir hören Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte fremdeln eventuell
mit diesem Begriff Integration Herr Tomé
für sie ist Integration dann aber schon
auch ein kultureller Begriff oder
es ist für mich jedenfalls ein ganz
positiver Begriff integration heißt auch
nicht Assimilation da muss ich jemand
genauso sein wie wir wobei auch das die
Frage ist was heißt eigentlich wie wir
ist Hamburger genauso wie der Münchner
der Bayer genauso wie der Hesse auch bei
uns gibt's ja ganz ganz viele
Unterschiede das darf auch sein wir
sagen ja zu einer vielfältigen eine
pluralgesellschaft wo jeder so sein darf
wie er sein möchte man muss seine
Herkunft verleugnen aber er muss eben
die Regeln anerkennen die bei uns gelten
das fängt mit der Rechtsordnung an was
unser Regeln sind steht im Grundgesetz
drin da hat es hat viel zu tun mit der
Gleichberechtigung von von Mann und Frau
das hat viel zu tun mit Toleranz mit
Meinungsfreiheit all das muss man
anerkennen es soll auch so sein dass
jemand wirtschaftlich auf eigenen Beinen
stehen kann das hat etwas zu tun mit
würde nicht abzuhängen nicht abhängig zu
sein von von staatliche Hilfe all das
ist ein Zeichen von gute Integration wer
da ange gekommen ist der fühlt sich ja
ganz anders sind auch stolz sein auf das
Erreichte das was er selber geschaffen
hat und solche Menschen wollen wir und
solche Menschen brauchen wir das sind
Beispiele Beweise das Integration und
Migration das Einwanderung gelingen kann
und das brauchen wir bei uns vor allem
weil es ja auch viele politische Kräfte
gibt die deutlich machen wollen dass
Migration was ganz furchtbares was
schlimmes was gefährliches sein kann und
wir wollen entgegen Beweis antreten
Integration Migration kann auch gelingen
ich würde gerne noch mal auf einer
Äußerung ihres FDP Generalsekretärs
zurückkommen der hat nämlich im Spiegel
kritisiert dass es den oder einen Posten
eines sogenannten Sonderbeauftragten der
vom Bund aus dann Länder bei
Abschiebungen unterstützt immer noch
nicht geschaffen worden sein und es gab
jetzt in den letzten Tagen so ein
bisschen das Gerücht dass auch diese
postensache vielleicht ein Grund sein
könnte warum einige Stimmen auf der FDP
sich gerade noch so querstellen zu etwas
was eigentlich im Koalitionsvertrag so
festgehalten war was sagen sie dazu
das ist eine völlig davon losgelöste und
entkoppelte Diskussion wir stellen da
keinen jungtim keine notwendige
Verbindung her das eine ist das eine und
das andere ist das andere aber richtig
ist dass wir schon wollen dass ich alle
Vereinbarungen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
dann am Ende auch umgesetzt und erfüllt
werden wir arbeiten das Stück für Stück
ab und jetzt wollen wir als nächstes
unbedingt dass die Arbeitskräfte
Einwanderung geregelt wird das ist für
uns der wichtige Punkt und das was Sie
ansprechen der sonderbevollmächtigte für
migrationsabkommen ist sicherlich auch
ein Teil davon wo wir mit anderen
Ländern vereinbaren wollen unter welchen
Voraussetzungen kann jemand ins Land
kommen das ist das für ein Geben und
Nehmen wie können wir etwa diese
Erleichterungen schaffen aber auf der
anderen Seite müssen auch wichtige
Herrenländer dann die Menschen die
außersichtlich sind wieder zurücknehmen
auch das gehört zu einem Fähren
migrationsabkommen dazu und dafür wollen
wir am Ende auch Sonne haben
ich habe hier eine Frage aus unserer
Community nämlich von Youtube Userin
Natascha Kallis die fragt wann hat denn
jetzt die Regierung vor diese Regeln zu
verändern über die wir hier sprechen
hätte mir können Sie uns das übersehen
dabei oder Herr Tommy
gerne Herr Domi wenn Sie möchten
angesprochen wenn wenn ich darf
dazu wir haben schon angefangen damit in
dieser Woche haben wir heute im
Innenausschuss werden wir am Freitag im
Plenum beschließen die ersten beiden
migrationspakete eins und zwei der
Chancen Aufenthalt und die Verfahrens
Beschleunigung wir wollen das
Asylverfahren auch Asyl
Gerichtsverfahren schneller vonstatten
gehen wollen aber auch Chancen bieten
für die Menschen die schon lange hier
geduldet sind und irgendwie im
Sozialsystem hängen bleiben weil sie
kein echt Aufenthaltstitel bekommen den
Leuten wollen wir einen guten Weg in den
Arbeitsmarkt eröffnen wir haben schon
angefangen damit am Ende des Weges
werden wir als
ampelkoalitionen mehrere solche
migrationspakete beschlossen haben und
wir sind mittendrin also die Koalition
ist da gut unterwegs und Trödel nicht
herum
wir sind auf jeden Fall gespannt was da
kommt ich habe hier noch zwei Kommentare
aus der Community zu dem Thema wir haben
einmal von einem YouTube User den
Kommentar meiner Meinung nach sollte die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft komplett
abgeschafft werden entweder möchte
jemand Bürger des einen oder anderes
oder des anderen Landes sein Punkt dann
aber auch wieder auf Facebook bei uns
jemand sagt Leute die hier in
Deutschland geboren und aufgewachsen
sind sollten automatisch die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen ohne wenn
und aber ohne Bedingungen also wir sehen
die Meinung zu dem Thema gehen
auseinander wir wollen ja jetzt heute
aber nicht nur über diesen Gesetzentwurf
zum einbürgerungsgesetz sprechen sondern
auch über die Eckpunkte zum Fachkräfte
Zuwanderungsgesetz die eben heute vom
Kabinett beschlossen wurden und worum es
da genau geht das zeigt uns jetzt Sarah
Lazar
Deutschland fehlen Fachkräfte und davon
viele etwa 400.000 müssten pro Jahr
zusätzlich ins Land kommen sagt die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit deshalb will
die Bundesregierung das Fachkräfte
Zuwanderungsgesetz nachbessern
vorgesehen ist ein Punktesystem die
Auswahlkriterien für Fachkräfte die
nicht aus der EU kommen sind unter
anderem Alter Qualifikation
Sprachkenntnisse und Berufserfahrung wer
ausreichend Punkte erfüllt soll eine
sogenannte chancenkarte erhalten
außerdem soll die Anerkennung eines
Abschlusses vor allem in handwerklichen
Berufen etwa bei kfz-mechatronikern
wegfallen Voraussetzungen sie haben
mindestens zwei Jahre Berufserfahrung
und einen im Herkunftsland staatlich
anerkannten Berufsabschluss
also fassen wir mal zusammen eigentlich
geht es bei dieser Nachbesserung des
Gesetzes darum die Hürden für
qualifizierte Zuwanderer und Zuwanderer
nach Deutschland zu senken an diesem
Vorhaben gibt es aber auch Kritik zum
Beispiel von Oppositionsführer Friedrich
Merz
wir haben in Deutschland ein
fachkräftereinwanderungsgesetz wir
brauchen mehr und wir schöpfen die
Potenziale die wir schon jetzt haben
nicht aus ich gebe Ihnen zwei drei
Beispiele wir haben in Deutschland 2,5
Millionen Arbeitslose auf als 1,9
Millionen offene Stellen da funktioniert
der Arbeitsmarkt nicht wir haben
Freizügigkeit in der Europäischen Union
aus allen Mitgliedstaaten der
Europäischen Union können Menschen nach
Deutschland kommen um hier zu arbeiten
ohne jede Bürokratie aber sie kommen
nicht weil die Bedingungen in
Deutschland einfach nicht gut genug sind
die Bürokratie ist furchtbar die Steuern
sind zu hoch und dann warten in den
deutschen Auslandsvertretungen im
Verantwortungsbereich von Frau bärburg
hunderte wenn ich tausende Fachkräfte
darauf endlich ein Visum zu bekommen und
sie bekommen es nicht weil die
Mitarbeiter nicht da sind und nicht
schnell genug arbeiten also das
Potenzial auch schöpfen wäre der erste
Schritt
ja wir hören Friedrich Merz der sagt es
gibt ja eigentlich schon so ein Gesetz
und warum arbeiten wir nicht mit dem
Potenzial was ist schon in Deutschland
gibt hätte mir wie würden sie dem
entgegnen
ja stimmt erstmal dass wir seit März
2020 einfachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
haben aber wenn man sich die Zahlen
anguckt funktioniert es nicht so gut
hat natürlich auch teilweise mit der
corona-pandemie zu tun aber wenn man
sich Zahlen anguckt
letztes Jahr sind ungefähr eine Million
Menschen aus Deutschland weggezogen und
1,2 Millionen Menschen sind ja nach
Deutschland zugezogen und die wenigsten
darunter waren tatsächlich Arbeitskräfte
und das müssen wir beschleunigen weil
wir sonst nicht auf den Nettozuwachs von
400.000 Menschen pro Jahr kommen werden
und das Argument mit
ja Arbeitslosen
EU-Bürgerinnen und so weiter also es
kommen die meisten kommen aus EU-Staaten
aber auch das reicht noch nicht und ich
will eine Zahl auch noch mal nennen bis
2035 werden etwa 7 Millionen Menschen
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt fehlen und es ist
ja bei den Arbeitslosen beispielsweise
so dass wir ja mit dem Bürgergeld ja
gerade auch die Qualifikation in diesem
Bereich ja auch sehen und die auch
voranbringen wollen auch mit
Weiterbildung und beruflicher Ausbildung
also da sind wir dran es ist nicht in
der Politik immer so dass man nur eine
Sache macht und die andere Sache nicht
sondern wir brauchen eine
fachkräftestrategie die wir auch haben
und Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz ist
ein Punkt und noch mal ganz kurz zu den
Arbeitslosen auch da ist der Fall so
dass wir nicht von heute auf morgen zum
Beispiel eine Person die gerade
arbeitslos ist so Pflegefachkraft machen
können sondern das braucht auch seine
Zeit deshalb würde ich das Argument von
März da auch noch mal zurückweisen
ein Teil diese dieses Eckpunktepapiers
ist ja auch das Punktesystem was wir da
gerade gesehen haben das ist ja ein
Modell was es schon aus
Einwanderungsländern gibt die das ganze
irgendwie sehr erfolgreich gestalten war
das auch irgendwo eine Inspiration Herr
Tomé
ja tatsächlich ist das genauso wie sie
sagen Länder wie Kanada wie Australien
wie Neuseeland also klassische
Einwanderungsländer legen solche
Kriterien an bilden diese Kriterien
einen Punktesystem ab um klar zu machen
welche Voraussetzung muss jemand
erfüllen um in den Arbeitsmarkt dieser
Länder einzuwandern das ist keine
Erfindung von uns sondern Best Practice
sozusagen und wir versuchen dieses
Modell zu übertragen auf unsere
Verhältnisse das kann man nicht so eins
zu eins übernehmen muss es auch
abwandeln und auf unser Land übertragen
aber das ist unser Vorbild und das
wollen wir auch tun weil wir feststellen
wir brauchen auch ein gewisses Maß an
Zuwanderung die Zahl ist eben genannt
worden 400.000 pro Jahr ist ja keine
Erfindung der Regierung oder der
Ampelkoalition oder der Fraktionen sie
wird genannt von den
Wirtschaftsverbänden und wir müssen
natürlich auch im Inland versuchen
Potenziale zu heben aber man kann das
eine tun ohne das andere zu lassen wir
müssen also bei uns im Inland versuchen
Menschen die noch vermittelbar sind in
den Arbeitsmarkt zu bringen aber wir
brauchen eben auch Zuwanderung aus dem
Ausland
dieses Punktesystem ist ja tatsächlich
in Deutschland etwas relativ neu ist das
Punktesystem wird aber auch kritisiert
zum Beispiel von ulfrinne Arbeitsmarkt
und zuwanderungs-
aber aus meiner Sicht
springt der Tiger trotzdem etwas zu kurz
weil das Gesetz wieder keinen
Befreiungsschlag ist der tatsächlich
notwendig ist um auf die geforderten
Zahl an Zuwanderung in den kommenden
Jahren und Jahrzehnten zu kommen
zum Beispiel löst die chancenkarte jetzt
im Gespräch ist also das Punktesystem
was quasi on top zu bestehenden
Regelungen kommt die zentralen
Herausforderungen weiter nicht das ist
erstens sind es die deutschen
Sprachkenntnisse und zweitens die
Anerkennung von ausländischen
Abschlüssen das steht weiterhin im
Mittelpunkt und die Verfahren drohen
sogar bürokratischer zu werden wenn
nämlich geprüft werden muss ob jemand
die geforderten Kriterien tatsächlich
erfüllt für dieses Punktesystem wir
müssen insbesondere den Unternehmen so
denke ich mehr Vertrauen schenken Sie
wissen am besten wäre für ihre
Tätigkeiten im Betrieb am besten auch
geeignet ist und dafür braucht es zum
Beispiel gar keine formalen Zertifikate
und in der Regel auch keine
nachgewiesenen Sprachkenntnisse sondern
wir sollten hier den der Fähigkeit der
Arbeitgeber Vertrauen geeignete
Bewerberinnen und Bewerber zu finden und
ihnen dafür dann den geeigneten und
passenden Rahmen bieten
ja also wir haben hier Ideen die es
eigentlich einfacher machen sollen nach
Deutschland zu kommen jetzt haben wir
hier ein Kritiker der sagt das führte zu
mehr Bürokratie und das vielleicht auch
in dem Land wie Deutschland was ja
bekannt ist für eine relativ hohe
Bürokratie hätte mir was würden sie dem
entgegnen
ich würde schon auch widersprechen ich
sage schon dass wir hier ein
Paradigmenwechsel haben wir haben es ja
im Beitrag davor auch gehört diese Zwei
plus zwei Regelungen dass man sagt wenn
jemand in einem Drittstaat im Ausland
eine Ausbildung gemacht hat die zwei
Jahre gedauert hat und diese Person eine
zweijährige Berufserfahrung auch in dem
Ausgangsland hatte kann diese Person mit
einem Jobangebot nach Deutschland kommen
ohne dass es ein langes
Anerkennungsverfahren gibt oder bzw es
gibt überhaupt gar keine
Anerkennungsverfahren und ähm der
Experte hatte ja gesagt dass wir den
Unternehmern mehr vertrauen sollen oder
den Unternehmen und das tun wir ja weil
wir sagen das Unternehmen weiß am besten
wenn es gerade braucht und da haben wir
ja diese Regelung zwei plus zwei
Regelungen wenn ich sie jetzt mal und
das wird die Bürokratie schon sehr
abbauen weil man nicht dann prüfen muss
vor der Einreise okay ist denn jetzt
eine Gleichwertigkeit in diesem Job
da oder nicht sondern die Person kann
kommen also wir vertrauen den
Unternehmern Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmern und ich glaube das ist ein
riesen Schritt und der zweite
Riesenschritt will ich auch hier einmal
sagen wir haben die westbalkanregelung
ja schon länger die sechs
westbalkanstaaten da können sogar
Menschen kommen die im klassischen Sinne
vielleicht nicht qualifiziert sind aber
ein Jobangebot in Deutschland haben das
werden wir auch noch mal ja ausweiten
und wir überlegen auch noch das wird
jetzt auch noch mal im parlamentarischen
Verfahren viel viel später auch noch mal
besprochen werden ob wir es auch
ausweiten auf andere Länder da
funktioniert es zum Beispiel relativ gut
uns erreicht hier aus der Community eine
Frage per Mail zu genau diesem System
was ja so ein bisschen oder zum
kanadischen System was ja Vorbild ist
für das geplante deutschpunktesystem und
zwar fragt der User Sebastian Watz per
Mail der Grundpfeiler des kanadischen
Systems ist zum Beispiel dass die
economic immigrants also die
wirtschaftseinwanderer keinen Anspruch
auf Sozialleistungen haben und wenn
jemand seinen Job verliert gehen muss
wie ist das in dem neuen Entwurf geplant
wenn z.B einen Einwanderer trotz
Qualifikation seinen Job nach einem Jahr
verliert
können Sie uns dazu was sagen können Sie
Sebastians Frage beantworten
ja bei uns ist auch vorgesehen dass
jemand der als Job seeker als jemand der
noch keinen Arbeitsalltag mitbringt
sondern über das Punktesystem ins Land
kommt um hier entweder eine ein
Ausbildungsplatz oder ein Arbeitsblatt
zu suchen in diesem einen Jahr
selbstständig sich finanzieren muss das
wäre also nicht möglich dass jemand ins
Land kommt von sozialen Leistungen lebt
und möglicherweise erfolglos bleibt bei
der Arbeitssuche nein es gehört mit dazu
zu diesem Punkt des System dass man in
diesem ein Jahr dass man Zeit hat zu
meine Arbeit zu finden auf einen Bein
stehen muss das übernehmen wir vom
kanadischen System
ich glaube die Frage geht ja aber dahin
wenn quasi jemand einen Job gefunden hat
den aber dann verliert was passiert dann
mit dieser Person
muss die wieder gehen nee hat ja keine
dauernde er hatte keine dauerhafte
Aufenthalts erlauben ist sondern ein
Arbeitsvisum befristet das heißt wenn er
die Voraussetzung dann nicht mehr
erfüllt dann müsste er das Land auch
wieder verlassen
wir haben hier noch eine andere Frage
es geht noch mal um die Verkürzung von
Fristen er hätte mir die richtet sich
speziell an sie und zwar ist die vom
YouTube User Ballas rosanetzki der fragt
durch die Verkürzung der Fristen werden
vermutlich Fachkräfte die als
Gastarbeiter in Deutschland tätig sind
in einem niedrigeren Anteil in die alte
Heimat zurückkehren wie große Effekte
erwarten Sie hier
das zu quantifizieren eine genaue Zahl
vorherzusagen ist natürlich ungeheuer
schwierig ich persönlich gehe schon
davon aus dass durch dieses
Auswahlverfahren wir sehr viele Menschen
bekommen die hier auch Fuß fassen können
das ist dann Sache der genauen
Ausgestaltung dieses Punkte Systems und
wenn wir hier auch Erfahrungen sammeln
dann wird sich davon bin ich überzeugt
zeigen dass diese Menschen dann auch bei
uns Arbeit finden können dass ich aus
und fortbilden denn es kommt ja niemand
zu uns ins Land um hier ein Sozialfall
zu werden die Menschen kommen ja nach
Deutschland weil sie hier glauben Arbeit
zu finden hier erfolgreich sein zu
können das ist ja eine eine innere
Motivation die Sie mitbringen und das
ist genau das was wir ausnutzen sollten
den Willen der Menschen bei uns durch
Arbeit ist etwas zu bringen das sollten
wir auch fördern und das sollten wir
auch die Hand ausstrecken genau für
solche Menschen
ihr merkt wir diskutieren hier ganz
verschiedene ganz komplexe Themen
deswegen öffne ich die Diskussion noch
mal so ein bisschen also hier sind ganz
viele Fragen auch noch mal zum Thema
Einbürgerung einbürgerungsgesetz hätte
mir hier ist eine Frage die richtet sich
an sie noch mal zum Thema doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft wenn es zu einem
Konflikt zwischen Deutschland und einem
Land kommt dessen zweite
Staatsbürgerschaft jemand besitzt was
ist das dann für eine Situation wie wird
sich da verhalten
okay es gibt verschiedene Beispiele
also es gibt eine diplomatische
Unterstützung konsularische
Unterstützung der Person also wenn wenn
die Person deutscher Staatsbürger ist
deutsche Staatsbürgerin ist aber wir
kennen das natürlich jetzt auch im Iran
das dann natürlich wenn da ist die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft von Grund
aufgegeben weil der das Land Iran ja
nicht ausbürgert und dann gibt es
natürlich es wird dann komplexer in
solchen Fällen aber ich würde das jetzt
nicht so einem Normalfall erheben
sondern den meisten Fällen ist hat man
die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft sondern
und man ist in beiden Ländern ja zu
Hause wenn man so will und man hat auch
eine diplomatische Unterstützung durch
den deutschen Staat aber wie gesagt in
diesen Einzelfällen wo es darum geht
dass man in Länder also den Pass eines
Landes besitztes sagen wir mal autoritär
ist dann wird es natürlich auch
komplizierter das will ich gar nicht
jetzt ein Abrede stellen aber es sind
halt erstmal Einzelfälle
wir haben hier noch eine ein Statement
von Lili weince auf Youtube die schreibt
ausbilden ausbilden ausbilden und daraus
würde ich jetzt einfach noch mal eine
Frage generieren wir wollen ja zum einen
dass Menschen zu uns nach Deutschland
kommen die qualifiziert sind und hier
arbeiten weil quasi der demografische
Wand auch einfach von uns erfordert es
gibt ja auch hierzulande Jugendliche die
nicht in Ausbildungsverhältnisse kommen
wie kann man denn da vorgehen was ist
denn da geplant das quasi auch mit dem
hier Menschen in bessere
Ausbildungsberufe kommen
ja ein eine Idee ist ja die wir
voranbringen wollen auch in der
Koalition ist die Ausbildungsplatz
Garantie also das haben wir auch im
Blick wie schaffen wir es wenn jemand ja
abgeht von der Schule dass diese Person
dann halt auch eine Garantie hat wie es
auch bei Menschen ist die beispielsweise
ja studieren Abitur haben da gibt's ja
vielleicht jetzt nicht den Wunschort
aber es gibt schon grundsätzlich die
Möglichkeit in Deutschland zu studieren
und diese Möglichkeit sollte es auch für
Jugendliche geben die dann Ausbildung
machen wollen plus da auch noch mal
wieder zurück zum Bürgergeld auch da
werden wir gucken der
vermittlungsvorgang fällt ja weg und da
ist es so dass wir dann sagen dass nicht
ein Jugendlicher oder junger Mensch dann
jeden Job annehmen muss die als
Hilfskraft sondern wir gucken erstmal
dass diese Personen Ausbildung bekommt
und dann dauerhaft auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
sein kann
wir haben noch einen Facebook kommentar
von Karin Heinemann die sagt manche sind
Jahre hier und können die Sprache
trotzdem nicht sie sagt es wäre schon
wichtig dass du können jetzt ist ja in
verschiedenen Maßnahmen auch geplant
dass quasi die Sprachbarrieren in
Deutschland auch um Beschäftigung zu
finden um einzuwandern ein bisschen
niedriger werden Herr Tomei was würden
Sie denn Karin Heinemann dazu sagen
also ich sehe das auch so die Sprache
ist schon ein ganz ganz wichtiger
Zugangspunkt zu unserer Gesellschaft ja
es gibt natürlich auch Ort es gibt auch
Firmen in denen nicht zwingend deutsch
gesprochen werden muss gibt ja auch
Menschen die in Unternehmen arbeiten in
Englisch die Unternehmenssprache ist und
sie dann auch ein paar Jahre hier
arbeiten ohne Deutsch zu lernen das ist
nicht völlig ungewöhnliches wir haben
auf Dauer nicht nur hier arbeiten
sondern hier auch leben will Teil
unserer Gesellschaft werden will der
kommt nicht drumherum unsere Sprache
jedenfalls so weit zu lernen dass er
sich auf normalen Niveau im Alltag damit
verständlich machen kann und deswegen
ist auch ganz wichtig dass wir
Integrationskurse anbieten dass wir
Sprachkurse anbieten und ja auch ein
Stück weit zu Voraussetzung dafür machen
dass jemand in Genuss aller Rechte
kommen kann vor allem bei der
Einbürgerung geht es ohne dass
sicherlich nicht und das muss schon
unser unser Ansatz sein dass ihr sagen
wer hier herkommt auch als Familien
Gebiet eines eine Person die hier
arbeitet der muss dann zumindest gleich
nachdem ins Land gekommen ist mit einem
Sprachkurs beginnen ansonsten wird
Integration nicht nicht funktionieren
und nicht gelingen können aber der beste
sprachhelfer der beste
Integrationshelfer ist und bleibt der
Kollege am Arbeitsplatz bleiben die die
Mitschülerinnen Mitschüler in der Schule
darauf setzen wir aber wichtig ist auch
dass wir ein echtes integrations- und
Sprachangebot machen
sie dem zu
ja also grundsätzlich dass die Sprache
sehr wichtig ist klar ein guter Punkt
wir haben aber tatsächlich Menschen hier
in Deutschland sie seit 30 40 Jahren
hier leben die hier gearbeitet haben
Kinder haben die jetzt auch Politik
machen im Bundestag sitzen die jetzt
diese
Sprachniveaus jetzt nach dem
europäischen Referenzrahmen B1 jetzt so
nicht haben nicht vielleicht auch nicht
erreichen werden und da haben wir ja
jetzt auch in diesem Gesetzentwurf die
Idee zu sagen da
gucken wir dass die Sprachnachweise
ja die Hürden dann nicht so hoch sind
weil wir einfach gesehen haben bei
diesen Menschen die sind ein Teil dieser
Gesellschaft und wir sehen dass diese
diese dieser Sprachnachweis für sie eine
ganz ganz ganz ganz große Hürde ist und
ich finde diese diese Gruppe hat es auch
verdient das ist eine nachholende
Anerkennung dieser Gruppe dass sie den
deutschen Pass bekommen und da können
wir auch mal sagen okay bei den
sprachnachweisen machen wir da kleinere
Abstriche
wir haben ja aus der Community noch eine
Stimme die quasi selbst weiß wovon sie
spricht nämlich von Erika von schimmere
sie sagt auf Youtube ich habe den Test
zur Einbürgerung erfolgreich absolviert
und denke dass es sehr wichtig ist dass
die deutschen Sprachkenntnisse sehr gut
sein sollen die Sprache ist das Tor zu
Verständigung dann habe ich hier noch
einen Kommentar per Mail bekommen von
Veronika sticht die sagt diese
Diskussion ist beschämen es geht nur um
Fachkräfte für unser Land kein Gedanke
welche Verluste den Herkunftsländern
hinzugefügt wird sie haben die
Ausbildung der Fachkräfte bezahlt und
ihnen gehen dann diese Bürger verloren
osteuropäischen Ländern fehlen zum
Beispiel Pflegekräfte ebenso wie bei uns
dieser Egoismus ist ein Skandal Herr
Thoma was können Sie Veronika sticht
darauf antworten
also das muss man ernst nehmen was Frau
sticht da schreibt oder sagt ja es gibt
natürlich immer noch einen gewissen
talentabfluss ein brain drain aus
Ländern wenn wenn vor allem junge
Menschen zu uns kommen das kann aber
auch in Austausch Verhältnis werden dass
Menschen nicht auf Dauer hier sind
manche gehen ja auch wieder zurück sie
bilden sich fort qualifizieren sich
weiter und gehen nach ein paar Jahren
zurück in die Heimatland und bringen
dann neue Qualifikationen weiter
Qualifikation mit auch Sprachkenntnisse
interkulturelle Kenntnis ein Netzwerk
das zu uns für das in diesem Land
weiterführen kann das kann auch ein
Geben und Nehmen sein das will ich da
dement gegenhalten aber es gibt eben
auch Länder in denen manche Menschen
nicht voran kommen würden weil es andere
Hindernisse geben würde zum Beispiel
eine eine kryptische Verwaltung weil
weil Menschen dort eine Minderheit
angehören die am Wort kommen gehindert
werden es kann auch Gründe geben deshalb
werden bei uns voran kommen kann in
seiner Heimat aber nicht du musst es
Differenz betrachten was Frau Stich
schreibt ist nicht falsch aber es ist
immer ein Teil der Wahrheit
hätte mir was sagen sie denn zu Frau
Stich
ja die Begriffe sind gerade auch
gefallen
also wir achten schon darauf
dass wir jetzt ja nicht massenhaft
Pflegekräfte
Menschen aus dem Pflegebereich aus dem
Gesundheitsbereich abwerben es gibt auch
internationale Verträge dazu an die man
sich halten muss also das haben wir im
Blick aber Fakt ist auch dass wir
natürlich gucken dass in es gibt Länder
in denen zum Beispiel Tunesien viele
hoch ausgebildete Menschen sind die
studieren aber dann keinen Job finden
und da macht es natürlich auch für die
Personen sind es macht für uns Sinn dass
sie dann zu uns kommen kann und hier
arbeiten kann und ja so wie Herr Thomas
auch gesagt hat wenn Sie wenn die Person
das möchte also ich möchte dass sie dann
in Deutschland bleibt aber wenn sie
möchte natürlich kann sie dann auch
wieder wieder zurück nach Tunesien und
da nochmal was aufbauen mit den
Erfahrungen die sie hier in Deutschland
aufgebaut hat aber da sind ja die Punkte
da sind die Menschen die wir erreichen
wollen das ist so unser Ziel auf jeden
Fall und nicht dass wir Menschen
abwerben wollen die in den eigenen
Ländern gebraucht werden
wir sehen Einbürgerung und
fachkräftezuwanderung zwei sehr komplexe
Themen die sich immer wieder berühren zu
denen die Ampelkoalition einige Pläne
hat sich vielleicht noch nicht an allen
Stellen einig ist ich denke ich spreche
auch für unsere Zuschauer und
Zuschauerinnen wir sind gespannt was da
in den nächsten Monaten in den nächsten
Wochen passiert und ich sage danke Herr
Demir danke Herr Thomas danke dass Sie
bei uns waren und Stellung bezogen haben
danke auch euch da draußen für eure
Fragen und Kommentare wir bleiben da auf
jeden Fall für euch dran und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder bei ZDF heute live
wenn ihr mögt macht's gut